[MUSIC PLAYING]
WES WAHLIN: Welcome
to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
My name's Wes.
And this is Mikhail.
And today we'll be talking
to you about Cloud TPUs.
You can ask questions at
any time on the platform.
And we've got Googlers
standing by to answer them.
So let's get started.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA:
Yeah, as Wes mentioned,
we're here to talk about
the Cloud, the Cloud TPU
Pod, a supercomputer
for deep learning
that packs 11 and 1/2
petaflops of performance.
My name is Mikhail Chrestkha.
I'm a Machine
Learning Specialist
within Google Cloud's
customer engineering team.
And Wes is our Cloud
TPU Product Manager.
In terms of our
agenda for today,
we'll start with what are TPUs.
We'll move onto the why,
and highlight a case study
with eBay, how they're
using Cloud TPUs
use to enable visual search.
We'll then jump into how.
And I'll walk
through a short demo
of how you can access Cloud TPUs
today on Google Cloud Platform.
And Wes will conclude
with a sneak peek
into the future of
the Cloud TPU pods.
And we'll end with Q and A.
So Wes, let's jump
right in and let's
start with around what was the
motivation behind developing
Cloud TPUs?
WES WAHLIN: Yeah,
thanks, so as you
can see here on this slide this
shows how models have increased
in size and have
increased an accuracy over
about the last
five to six years.
And this has been really
quite phenomenal how fast
these things have grown.
The amount of compute needed to
bring this kind of performance
has been astounding.
And so from that
we realized that we
needed to build
something that was more
specialized to deep learning.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA: Yeah,
yeah, very interesting.
I guess in today's
current landscape
the multi-purpose
hardware accelerators,
they might not be enough
to really further push AI.
And we talk about new fields
such as autonomous systems,
robotics, and things that are
very important like safety
and health care, where every
percentage point really
matters.
And we want to get
to 85, 90, 95%.
That's really where we believe
that specialized hardware
purpose built for ML can really
advance AI moving forward.
So let's talk about exactly what
these hardware accelerators are
and what they look like.
WES WAHLIN: Yeah, so these are
the TPUs, Tensor Processing
Units.
And they're ASICs.
And they're
specifically designed
to do machine learning.
And ASIC is Application
Specific Integrated Circuit.
And these are
literally just that.
They're specifically designed
to run deep neural networks
and do the math that powers
deep neural networks.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA: Yeah, so we
see a lot of generations here.
Why didn't we stop at
version 1 three years ago?
WES WAHLIN: Oh sure, so
in 2015 in this slide,
you can see that we started
with a very simple processor.
We wanted to see what
we could do with it.
This one specifically
just did inference,
so already taking a train
model and being able
to output what the computer
thinks it's seeing.
And we soon realized
that this is amazing.
It's awesome.
It's a good thing
to keep pursuing.
So we made TPU v2.
And we increased the
amount of compute
that it did quite
phenomenally to 180 teraflops.
And then we kept going TPU
v3 that we just announced,
420 teraflops per device.
And you can see on that device
that there's four chips.
And they're all
working together.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA:
Yeah great, so here we
have some snapshots the chips.
But today we're really here
to talk about the pods.
So let's jump in and
really talk about
the different granularities,
all the different methodologies
around using these.
WES WAHLIN: Yeah, so there's
some terminology here.
So we talk about on
like on that last slide,
you can see here with one board,
which has four chips on it.
And then as you get into
a larger configuration,
that board is able to talk to
other boards and other chips
in a very high speed way so
that they all basically act
like one accelerator.
And then we call that full
configuration a full pod,
where we can take
64 of those devices
and hook them all together
and network them in such a way
that they're all
essentially acting like one.
And that's where
we get a full pod.
And then we also
offer the ability
to do that in smaller chunks.
And we call those slices.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA: So
it's not all or nothing.
We do have the small
granularity, the full pod,
but we have a lot of
different slice options.
Quick question, why not more
combinations or permutations
of those slices?
I see three here in the middle.
WES WAHLIN: Right,
these are kind
of the optimal way that they
can communicate together.
So when we talk about how they
do their actual matrix math,
these are the optimal
configurations in which
they can operate at full speed.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA: I see.
So a lot of terminology,
we have cores.
We have chips.
We have devices, slices, pods.
But the key takeaway is really
around the number of cores.
That's really the key metric.
And that's where the
naming convention really
follows, when we
have the v2 followed
by the number of cores
available to you as an end user.
WES WAHLIN: Yeah, exactly.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA:
So now let's dive
in a little bit
into the low level.
What is actually
happening on these chips?
WES WAHLIN: Right, as we go down
and we focus in on one chip,
this is kind of the
heart of the TPU.
And as you can see
in this animation
that the matrix math
is done from one corner
to the following corner.
And this is how
the TPUs function.
They do very simple linear
algebra and matrix math.
And how that is
computed is essentially
like a heart would
be pumping blood.
And that's where the
systolic array gets its name.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA: I see.
So they're not too versatile,
but for matrix multiplication
specifically they're super fast.
And I guess you see, everyone
should see the tpudemo.com.
Feel free to take a look.
It actually has a voiceover
and a deeper explanation
around this visual as
well as comparisons
across your more
traditional hardware,
such as CPUs and GPUs.
So we are here to
talk about full pods,
so taking that performance that
Wes just mentioned and really
scaling it up.
So Wes, can you talk
about how this scales up?
WES WAHLIN: Yeah, so hinted
at this a little bit earlier,
but this is how they
communicate at a full pod level
to do a propagation through each
and every parameter calculation
in a linear fashion.
So it scales perfectly.
So as you get up
to a full pod you
don't have to change any code.
All you have to do is
increase your batch size.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA: I see.
And hardware might be
able to intimidating,
but as a data
scientist and someone
who focuses on ML code,
what really makes me smile
is that line linear performance
scaling without code changes.
So that's great, where I can
code once and then scales
seamlessly.
WES WAHLIN: Yeah.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA:
So Wes, I think
we're excited to announce
that these pods are
available to the
broader community.
Can you take us into
some of the specs?
WES WAHLIN: Yeah, so these
pods are available today.
And we have them in alpha.
And when you utilize
a full pod you
can get about 11.5 petaflops
of actual DNN compute.
And your models can
be extremely large,
so up to four terabytes
of high bandwidth memory.
And then of course
they're all connected
in that 2-D torus,
which basically
means that every chip
kind of acts as one
chip altogether
at the same time.
And there, and I should
mention that it's
training and inference.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA: Wow, I
mean, this is fascinating,
as one of the internal
end users being
able to just log
into a web browser,
log into my Google
Cloud Platform account,
and to be able a provision
a full supercomputer
without worrying about
capital expenditures,
setting up the hardware,
and being able to train
these massive models.
It's really fascinating.
We're really excited to enable
all our customers and partners
to be able to leverage these
as part of their ML processes
as well moving forward.
So we'll jump now
into a little bit
of the why around this, and
really around the business
applications.
And first off, you
know, why pods?
Deep learning overall really
takes a lot of experimentation.
It's more of an art
as much as a science.
So when we talk about
pods right away,
the quick win is
rapid experimentation.
Number two, we talked
about this around coding
once and seamlessly scaling.
So you're really a
lot more productive
as a data scientist, so which
allows you to amplify your work
across the organization.
Number two, we're
also at a point
where these models are getting
very large and very complex.
Not only can we not fit
data on one machine,
there are moments
where we actually
can't fit the actual
model on the machine.
We're getting to the point
where there's millions, even
billions of parameters.
So being able to
leverage all these cores,
all this memory allows
us to experiment
with very, very large models
and a lot of merging spaces.
And finally, as a lot of
industries and customers
move into more of a
personalization service,
really creating these
rich customer experiences,
when we talk about
recommendations, visual search,
localized translations
for each region,
and even very important things
like medical transcriptions,
that's really where
we believe having
up-to-date fresh data that
really is able to stay
intelligent as
your users evolve,
and their habits
change, it really
gets you one step closer
to a continuous learning
loop moving forward.
So that's a little bit
around why we truly believe
that pods can help out today.
And how can you help out even,
how can you start even sooner?
So Wes, can you go over
some of the reference models
that are readily available
and optimized for TPUs?
WES WAHLIN: Yeah, so
TPUs have a set of what
we would call optimized models.
And these are ones that are
available on GitHub today.
And they cover these
four basic sections
of deep neural networks
so that you can do
pretty much whatever you want.
And you can get started
with these today.
So these are all
available on GitHub.
And you can do
image recognition,
and object detection, machine
translation, and language
modeling with transformer,
as well as speech recognition
and image generation.
But you can see like for object
detection and recognition,
we have various
models available.
And these have been
in the industry
as long as we've
been doing this.
And it showed on that
first graph that we had.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA:
And while these
might be familiar names for
folks who are already immersed
in the deep learning
space, I do want
to dive a little bit into this
for folks who are just joining
the deep learning community.
In traditional ML, you
usually just select
a machine learning technique.
You might choose regression
or classification.
You might use a technique
like random forest or decision
trees.
But there's one additional
layer in the process when
you talk about deep learning.
And that's actually
architecting these models.
And this is what these reference
models are referring to.
How many layers
deep is the model?
How many nodes per layer?
What are the actual properties
for each of the nodes?
Are they short term, long term?
Are they recurrent or not?
So when we talk about names
like AmoebaNet, Inception,
Transformer, these are
actually ready-to-use models
that you can apply today
to your business problems,
in the image space,
whether you're
looking at product
quality on a factory line
or stock outs on a
physical floor space.
So I just want to kind of
clarify that these actually
are ready to use.
They're not just machine
learning techniques.
These are fully
architected models that
are ready to use on your data.
And then moving forward,
we want to highlight
one customer that was an
early user of TPU pods, eBay.
WES WAHLIN: Yeah,
so eBay came to us.
And they wanted to be able
to speed up their training.
Currently they had done a
massive amount of On-Prem work.
And it took them quite
a while to do training,
and sometimes even took months.
We were able to provide
them with some new model
and new model support,
as well as some TPUs,
and were able to increase
their training by over 100x,
as well as increasing their
accuracy 10%, which accuracy
is kind of the name of the
game, how high can you get it.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA: Yeah,
I mean the performance
results are really amazing.
But really let's talk
about the size of this.
Why were TPU pods
really useful here?
And if you look at just the
catalog listing of eBay,
one of the staples of Silicon
Valley, one billion product
listings at this point as well.
And for the test that
we did with them,
they actually ran a model on
55 million product images,
and to be able to predict over
10,000 product categories.
So this is a very, very
large scale problem
that would not be able to be
solved without Custom Hardware
Accelerators.
WES WAHLIN: Yeah,
and the largeness
of how much memory is available
on the TPU pods is key.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA: Absolutely.
So now let's jump into how
do you actually get started.
Before we dive into that,
I want to talk about
who is this for really?
How are we positioning TPU pods?
The easy answer might be
this is for the deep learning
researchers and the
data scientists.
And that answer is correct.
It's going to allow you to
scale and amplify your work.
But really the broader
mission of Google Cloud
is also to enable the
developers, the data analysts,
the business analysts,
the 20 plus million
out there that want to
leverage machine learning.
So TPUs today, if you
know Python, especially
with these reference
models that Wes mentioned,
you can get started today on
practical pragmatic business
applications.
Also, we understand that
you might have already
done a lot of work on
developing a ML infrastructure.
We really want to make sure
we have minimum disruption.
So if you do want
to leverage TPU pods
for training large models,
you can still take that model
and still serve them within
your existing CPU or GPU serving
infrastructure.
Now how do we actually
provision a TPU pod?
Everything is
through Google Cloud.
You log into the Google
Cloud Platform console.
And really actually
it's just one command.
There's a nice utility
tool where in this case,
it's CTPU up.
And then you specify the size
that Wes mentioned, anything
from the normal TPU
device with eight cores,
all the way up to
a full pod of 512.
But what exactly does
this CTPU up command do?
And it does a number of things.
Number one, it provisions
a host VM, a CPU.
This is pre-installed
with TensorFlow.
Today it's with
TensorFlow version 1.12.
But you can specify the
version of your needs.
And what the CPU actually
acts as the TensorFlow client.
This has a TensorFlow code.
It actually serves up
the TensorFlow graph
to the TPU pod.
It also takes all
the images that
are stored in Google
Cloud Storage bucket
and feeds it into the TPU pod.
And the TPU pod essentially
acts as the TensorFlow server
in this case.
Also while you're
using this, it's
important to note that TPU pods
are accessible through two APIs
currently, the TPU
Estimator and Keras,
for those who are more
familiar with that framework.
There's a number of
tools that are expanding
around being able to monitor
and profile your TPU workloads.
TPU profiler allows
you to take a look
at a lot of metrics
like utilization
to make sure that TPUs are
being used most effectively.
And TPU compatibility
checker is a plugin
to TensorBoard with a screenshot
in the right side of the slide
to make sure that
your actual TensorFlow
code is optimized for TPUs.
There's a great YouTube
video in the bottom right
from our colleague Brennan
during the TensorFlow Def
Summit that talks a
bit more around all
the tools available to you
as you develop on TPU pods.
So now we do want to walk
you through a practical demo
and first going through the
end to end demo architecture.
So first, we start
with the raw images.
And those are hosted on our
object storage web service
called Google Cloud Storage.
In this case, I'll go through
an example around ImageNet.
Second, we really want
to pre-process data,
whether it be feature
engineering on tabular
data, data augmentation
for images,
we want a quick way to get
your data ready for training,
and in this case, also
converting to TF records.
And that's really where Apache
Beam or a managed service
on Cloud Dataflow comes in.
Finally, once the data is
ready in Google Cloud Storage,
you submit that to the TPU
pod using the architecture
with the host VM, and the
TPU that I mentioned before.
And finally, the model is
outputted into a storage bucket
for you to use as needed,
or even export and use it
as part of your
current infrastructure.
Finally, there's a lot of
different options to serve.
One of them is to
serve those models
on our serving infrastructure,
on Cloud Machine Learning
Engine.
So this is a great
end to end pipeline.
And we also suggest
that you have a method
to orchestrate and automate
this using Cloud Composer, which
is our managed Apache
Airflow solution.
If you were you were watching
the webinar before us,
with Anand and Till, around
Kubeflow pipeline's AI hub,
really see a reference
architecture like this,
a great asset to reuse
across the organization.
So we really are going
to put in a lot of work
to take this pipeline
with TPU pods
and really add it into
a Kubeflow pipeline
and make it more discoverable
as part of the broader AI hub
community.
So now let's jump
into the actual demo.
So for those who are not
familiar with ImageNet,
it is a image catalog of indexed
and labelled data that is
widely used within the
research community.
In this case, I'm going through
a couple of examples here.
And for those of you
who are big Disney fans,
I know "The Lion King" is
coming up in 2009, so you
have just a quick example here.
For the lion cub image, we
actually have over 1,600
tagged images of lion cubs.
But again, I believe
ImageNet, at this point,
has millions and millions of
tagged images across 20,000
categories.
That is great for research.
And then you can use
a lot of these models
and then apply them onto
your own custom data set.
Also I talked about a lot of
the pre-processing of the data.
We actually have a lot of
toolkits available directly
in the TPU repo on GitHub
to be able to do that.
Things like downloading the
ImageNet dataset that I just
talked about and
transforming it in TF records
done for you automatically.
If you have your own images
across your unique product
catalog, your unique
taxonomy, there's
actually a JPEG to TF
record Python script that's
readily accessible for you.
Now, let's jump in into
Google Cloud Platform.
And I mentioned that with
one command, CTPU up,
you can actually
provision a host machine
pre-install with TensorFlow,
as well as a full TPU pod.
And this is the screen
for Google Compute Engine,
where you have your VMs.
And then we also take
a look at the TPU
available here right now.
Right now I have a pre-installed
host VM with a TPU.
I'm actually going to
run a quick example just
to show you how quickly
this can be done by anyone.
And I'm going to bring
up our quick Cloud Shell.
This can also be run
on a local command line
instance, or your local
development environment
where the Google Cloud
SDK is pre-installed.
I'm going to run this command.
And I won't wait for
it to fully provision.
But as you can see already, with
one command the Cloud OnAir TPU
VM, host VM is being
instantiated as we speak.
Now I'm going to actually SSH
into an existing, my existing
virtual machine.
And to really get started
with the reference models,
the only step you need
to prepare for is just
cloning the GitHub repo.
In this case, I'm cloning
one of our resonant models
within the TPU model's
official repository.
And it comes
pre-installed with a lot
of files that are ready for
you to train and evaluate
those models moving forward.
I'm going to quickly move to
Google Cloud Storage bucket.
I mentioned, we are going to
save the model in a Google
Cloud Storage bucket for you
to be able to monitor the usage
as well as be able to
export that as needed.
I will create models 8 as
I have while testing here.
As I prepare this model I'm
going to set some environment
variables, change this to 8.
And I'm just going to run
the training Python code.
Again, Python is what
you need to get started.
And really we're
off to the races.
So we're off to the races.
If I scroll down--
I know we have a
lot of noise here--
but I just want to
show you one piece here
where right away we've noticed
I've used a quarter pod here.
So it's realize there's
128 cores, 16 TPU workers
available for me to train this.
Again, the code is
written for one TPU,
or all the way up
to a full pod here.
And as I now go back to the
new bucket that I just created,
now while all magic is
happening I hit refresh.
This is where the model
training is occurring.
The model file is
going to be exported.
And all the check points
for all the updated variable
weights are going to be saved.
And I might just wait
about 5, 10 seconds just
to see one or two files.
There's the graph that
we're going to use.
And we'll continue to see
the checkpoints continually
be saved as we move forward.
So that's how easy it was
for me to get started.
I actually created the TPU,
or provisioned the TPU,
I should say, with
the CTPU up command.
I cloned to GitHub repo.
And then I ran the training job.
Now as I move
forward, I also might
want to look at what
is my performance here.
So I am going to open up
Cloud Shell one more time
and use one of my other
buckets from a previous model
that I wrote to actually
run TensorBoard.
So we have TensorBoard here.
I'm going to bring up
the UI, change the port.
And this will bring up
the TensorBoard dashboard.
This is a completed
model that I had
to run earlier this morning,
took about 25 minutes
to run through.
And a couple of metrics around
really the power of the TPU
pod, first the images
per second fluctuated
between about 66,000 images
per second to 68,000.
So that's really utilizing
the performance there.
When we talk about
the loss, again, I
can see my loss training and
also my final evaluation data
point there, and seeing
the loss increase up
until the optimal manner.
And most importantly,
what was my accuracy.
So accuracy can be
measured in a lot of ways.
I think in image classification,
top 1 or top 5 accuracy
are great standard benchmarks.
In this case as I zoom
in, the top one accuracy
for this example, along with the
hover over, was actually 76%.
And top 5 accuracy, if you're
OK with the right result being
in one of the top five
highly probable classes,
was actually 93%.
So moving back, moving
back to our slides here,
really I spun up a quarter pod,
was able to get to almost 68,
69,000 images per
second utilizing
that full TPU pod,
reach an accuracy of 76%
in under 25 minutes.
And overall, Wes is going
to talk about the prices,
but it cost me less
than $50 to do this.
This is quite fascinating,
where this would not be possible
just a few years ago.
WES WAHLIN: Right, the
25 minutes is phenomenal.
And that's just
utilizing a quarter pod.
And if you wanted to scale
that up to a full pod,
you can drop that literally.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA:
Yeah, absolutely.
So let's dive in a little
bit more into the pricing
and what's available on GCP.
WES WAHLIN: Yeah, so you
can see in the chart here
we start out at the
top with TPU devices.
And you can see the price
for v2 and v3 there.
And then all the other
ones that are kind of
shaded in white, and
then down to the full pod
there, those are the prices per
hour for each individual slice
of a pod.
And honestly, like
when you start
to get into like the quarter
pod, and half pod, and full pod
arena, you're really
focusing on time.
Like those times are going
to be phenomenally fast.
So if your business is
concerned about time,
like those are the
places that you
want to think about
increasing the throughput
of your training.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA: Absolutely.
So I think we also
want to give you
a sneak peek into the future.
So Wes, can you talk about
some of the new upcoming items
on Cloud TPU?
WES WAHLIN: Yeah, and
we talked about earlier
how the models that
are currently supported
are out on GitHub, that we also
have an experimental section.
And you'll see some
of these already
in the experimental section.
So data parallelism with
distribution strategy as well
as PyTorch Support,
these are all
coming in the very near future.
And TF, TensorFlow
2.0 is going to have
a lot of extended
functionalities for TPU.
And so with that, stay
tuned for live Q and A.
We'll be back in
less than a minute.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA: Great,
welcome back, everyone.
So we're going to go through
a couple of questions
from the audience.
The first question is, how
do I get access to TPU pod?
As Wes mentioned,
we're announcing
that they are available
to the public today.
If you go on our public
TPU documentation web site
you'll see the
instructions there.
Also feel free to reach out
to a Google account team.
And we'll get you access.
From a tactical
standpoint, there
might be steps for you to go
into your Google Cloud Platform
project and request quotas
if you really want access
to a high number of cores.
WES WAHLIN: Yeah.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA:
Second question,
can you run custom
models on TPU pods?
We've gone through a lot of this
session talking about reference
models, ready-to-use models
in the spaces of image,
language, and video.
But yes, you can run
custom models on TPU pods.
There are certain libraries
within the TensorFlow
framework, TPU Rewrite
and TPU Estimator
that allow you to port over
your existing TensorFlow
models into models that run
efficiently on TPU pods.
They just take a little
bit of extra work.
WES WAHLIN: Cool.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA: Wes, you
want to take the next question?
WES WAHLIN: Yeah,
so next question
is, what are petaflops?
So when we think about
like really large compute,
we start talking about how
big and how fast they go.
So when you talk
about a flop, that's
a floating point
operation per second.
And when you talk
about a petaflop,
you're talking about
1,000 teraflops.
So that when you go and
you do this compute,
you can do it that much faster.
So it's just large, large
scale supercomputing.
And the next step up
from that is exaflop.
So right now with TPU pods,
we're at 11.5 petaflops.
So that's the
amount of throughput
that you're able to get
with your matrix math.
And let's see, and
then the next one.
Starting at the smallest
TPU size, what changes do
I need to make to
scale to a TPU pod.
Well, that we've made
that very simple.
And on that one slide
we talked about how
there's no code changes.
The basic change that you
have to make is batch size.
And that's because the
memory is increasing.
So you want to increase
the batch size.
And that's how you keep
the TPU pod fully loaded.
So every time that
systolic array
goes and starts
chunking through all
of your layers
and your DNN, it's
going to always be full of data.
And so that's how you
get all the way up
to a full pod, so a
change in the batch size.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA:
That's a great point.
Code changes for the actual
training code, minimal to none,
but you might want
to look into changing
hyper parameters to fully
utilize the larger slices.
WES WAHLIN: Yeah, and
last question here.
How much of Google's
infrastructure
is running on TPUs?
Well as you've probably seen
over the past couple of years,
as you start talking to things
that Google makes a little bit
more, we're doing actually
quite a bit on TPUs.
It's so much more
efficient, power efficient,
compute efficient,
and density-wise
that we're able to pack so
much more compute into our data
centers.
So for Cloud TPUs,
that's something
that we run most of
what you see for machine
learning on the products
that you use today.
And for resources, you can
go to these links here.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA:
Yeah, absolutely.
The first link is really our
public TPU documentation,
and also answer the question
of how do I get access to TPUs.
So those will be
the instructions.
The second link is
a great slide deck
from our developer relations
team that's been put together.
tpudemo.com talks a little
bit around the low level
architecture of
TPUs and compared
to other traditional
hardware accelerators.
And finally the GitHub
repo that gives you
access to a lot of our
official optimized models,
experimental models,
and a lot of those kits
that allow you to
pretty process your data
to be fully utilized
by TPUs pods.
WES WAHLIN: Yeah, and stay
tuned for the next session, how
to build custom data
visualizations in Data Studio.
And thank you very much.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA:
Thank you so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]